Howard back from bleach report here on
the program how are you Howard um I'm
good I'm good let's get into this thing
right here the latest is apparently that
the pelicans are beginning to put the
Lakers ill-at-ease
to try and pull something off over the
next two days what do you think here
well I think that in a way it's not any
different than where we've been the
whole time rich in the sense that if the
pelicans really were enamored of what
the Lakers could offer this could have
been done I think a week ago it's not so
much a matter of like how much of the
Lakers willing to put in listen let's be
honest if the if the Lakers really want
to Anthony Davis and if the pelicans
like any variation of Laker players and
picks the Lakers would say okay great
what did tell us what it takes we'll
throw it all in because that's what you
do now listen there is such a thing I
suppose is overpaying because you do
need a supporting cast you do need
players around LeBron and Anthony Davis
eventually but the fact is if you can
get Anthony Davis a top five top seven
wherever you want to put him player in
the NBA of potential MVP and pairing
with LeBron immediately because the
clock is ticking on the bronze career
you do it the fact is we're at this
stage still because everyone knows that
one the Lakers assets aren't all that
that we all thought they might be maybe
a year ago Angermann ball just haven't
done enough to where people think okay
those are my franchise stars wait for
your LA or if you're a team trying to
acquire them and on top of that Boston
is lurking out there with what could be
the best potential trade package
Zion Williamson's lurking out there with
a team as yet unknown in the NBA and if
you're the pelicans why rush into a deal
with the Lakers where you think their
assets are kind of met where you could
instead wait see who gets the draft
rights design Williamson if he interests
you and see what the Celtics will
finally put together in July when
they're eligible to make a deal
especially if two as well that you feel
let you're being put in a bad position
by clutch sports by LeBron James
agency because and the reason why I
bring this up is for them again to come
out and say we're not resigning there
and we want to trade incurring a $50,000
fine which I know is a mere bag of
shells here for them to do this it puts
the pelicans in an awful position of
having to ride out if Anthony Davis is
willing to do it two and a half months
of fan anger unpopularity I mean they've
already removed him from the hype video
that they play in the smoothie King
before the game so why give anybody what
they have tried to put you in an awkward
position to get Howard do you think any
part of that is is folded into this it
might be rich nobody likes to be
manipulated I can't imagine anybody with
the pelicans organization appreciates
the fact that every single day there's
another drip or tweet coming from
Anthony Davis's camp you know various
ways of trying to pressure them into
making a deal now whether it's Anthony
Davis senior speaking out about how the
Celtics treated Isaiah Thomas whether
it's every single day somebody tweeting
some version of he's not going to resign
with us with the Celtics he doesn't want
to go to Boston I mean it's you know I
don't think we've ever seen a campaign
orchestrated quite like this and yeah if
you're the pelicans you probably resent
that that said you don't make a deal or
not make a deal based on those emotions
or resentments you make the best deal
that you can for your franchise to
ensure its health and competitiveness
going forward and if you think that that
deal can be on the table this week then
by all means make it but if you think
that the best deal is the one that might
be waiting for you July 1st then you
hold off you are under no obligation as
an organization to trade Anthony Davis
to the destination of his choice or his
agents choice or LeBrons choice you're
obligated to do the best thing for your
team now is that possibly warping the
market that he's that he's saying I only
want to go to these four teams which by
the way at least two of them are not
even viable but yeah that could be
warping the market a little bit but
again the pelicans you know have to make
the decision and the team that was
trading for him if they're willing to
roll the dice they're not on the list
and they roll the dice they can do that
it worked out pretty well for Oklahoma
City when they rolled the dice on Paul
George who supposedly wanted to only be
in LA and so far so good for
with Kawhi Leonard who only wanted to be
in LA so which teams used to think are
not viable on the list of teams that are
again that apparently Davis is forwarded
to the pelicans yeah yeah the 14 most
yesterday was kind of funny because it
was the Lakers which we you know
obviously that's his target and the
Clippers which is interesting you know
the Clippers are I think definitely
viable they got a lot of different
pieces they could trade they've got all
their pics that they could put in trade
I believe and they've got a supporting
cast that you could win with with even
after trading whatever you trade for
Anthony Davis I don't know if they
actually have unless they're gonna trade
che Gill just Alexander which they'd
have to like that's the top of the list
so they have an interesting combination
they maybe could put together but the
Knicks in the Bucs the next just traded
their best asset kristaps porzingis as a
means to offload bad contracts to dallas
they don't have anything left to trade I
mean Kevin Knox and Frank Neil aquinnah
and picks is not going to do it I don't
think um I don't see how the Knicks were
even in this and even if you did trade
those guys now you really have nothing
Anthony Davis is gonna be playing with
you know mannequins and the Bucks you
know look at Yanis Anthony Davis pairing
would be phenomenal I would love to see
that if if that came to pass but the
Bucks even though they don't have the
means to make that deal because their
best supporting cast players are
mid-career veterans who are all expiring
deals you know Malcolm Brogdon and Eric
Bledsoe and Chris Middleton you can't if
you're the pelicans you can't acquire a
bunch of guys who are on expiring
contracts so basically so basically
again they're with this list and with
everything that they've said so far the
Davis camp is basically telling the
pelicans you need to make a deal now
because don't wait for Boston to come
available because he doesn't want to go
there and whatever Boston would give you
to try and hedge that bet won't be any
as good as what you can get right now
which again comes back to my main point
of them being put in a position and
they've got pretty much 48 hours to
either get over that feeling of the
position and try and get as much as you
can right now and pull a deal or they'll
roll the dice
see what the Celtics will cough up when
comes July that said Kyrie might not be
there I mean how do you fold all this
together with the Kyrie stuff Howard
yeah the Kyrie thing is interesting a
couple of months ago somebody told me
listen take take this to the bank
Kyrie nad our buddies they've been
texting each other they would love to
play together and this is all gonna go
into coming to play next summer you know
that with you know with Anthony Davis
you know doesn't sign the extension this
was back before he decided announced
that he wouldn't and that would be part
of his incentive to going to Boston
which would be to play with a resigned
Kyrie and whoever else is there we have
more ambiguity in that whole situation
now because kairi's comments have you
know cause people to question his
commitment ahead Chris Mannix on my
podcast last Friday Chris obviously
based in Boston does TV up there knows
that organization as well as anyone he
says you know they still believe Kyrie
Irving is in this thing there that he's
staying and so look there's also been a
lot of whispers about Kai Reed you not
from Kyrie but from people real sources
around the league that kind of stuff
that has clouded this weather that is
also part of the orchestrated campaign
to create doubt about a possible Celtics
Anthony Davis marriage and to to muddy
the waters further and spook people I
maybe maybe not it's honestly there's
there's so much smoke right now it's
hard to know what the truth is the full
48 podcast you're referring to Howard
back from Bleacher Report home of that
podcast in all of his reporting right
here on the Rich Eisen show and then you
made mention of it and there's the next
man I mean where they go ahead with
Anthony Davis rumored to be on out there
right just right I don't know if this
happened yeah it happen right at the
same time clutch sports comes out and
say we're not we're not we're not coming
back New Orleans and we're we're we're
we're want to trade Knicks don't wait
for all that they have to offload
porzingis right away and you can you can
make the case that by creating to max
contracts that that and getting rid of
the awful Hardaway jr. contract and
keeping Knox
and nila kena and getting Dennis Smith
who Phil going out the door didn't draft
and draft into latina anyway and they've
got them all together you could make the
case that if they get the two folks that
they need this summer
brilliant trade certainly if porzingis
doesn't need to be there that said with
the ping ball ping pong balls need to
bounce their way also what do you think
of this move how risky do you think it
is Howard well what I wrote last week
rich was that this was either a
phenomenal gamble which if it pays off
yes I mean it could pay off to to
incredible degree and if it fails you
know everybody probably gets fired but
it is either an incredible gamble
trading away your lone young all-star
and not even in his prime yet for the
hope the possibility of signing two
stars if it's not a gamble then it's the
other thing and the other thing is that
you already believe you've got at least
one guy if not two in the bag in which
case it is the greatest tampering job in
the history of the NBA the reason I say
that is not just to be cynical but
because people around the NBA have felt
for months that Kevin Durant was going
to New York and that his camp had
signaled to the Knicks he's coming now
me personally I'm very first or January
31st when they make the deal was five
months to go or six months five months
five months to go until free agency
opens that's still a big risk even if
somebody has told you hey he's coming a
lot can change in five months and we've
seen that to happen before in the NBA
things change quickly so either they
know he's coming and they did this with
the confidence of knowing that this this
is not a gamble at all but they just got
to create the room because he's coming
and he's gonna bring somebody with him
or or just a tremendous gamble I would
also say rich is one quick addendum and
it's something that gets glossed over
this a lot yes it makes we're gonna have
close to max cap room for one guy anyway
they didn't need to make a move of this
magnitude to get to one max slot they
only made a move of this magnitude to
get to two max slots and you know look
it cost them their franchise star last
one for you Howard crystal ball at
forming what do you think happens over
the next 48 hours prior to Thursday's
deadline well let's take care of the big
one first
I don't think Anthony Davis gets traded
you know it's altogether possible
and maybe all this pressure and all this
noise and everything will add up to the
pelicans deciding you know what let's
just get it over with and get it done
sent him to LA fine maybe that happens I
don't think so the logical thing for
them to do is to wait and I think that's
probably what will happen outside of
that you know look Mike Conley being on
the move wouldn't surprise anyone or
Marcus all of course we know those guys
are both on the block anything outside
of those you know I there's nothing that
I would I would you know stake my
reputation on predicting the NBA trade
market is is often hard to read even
when there's a lot of people with motive
to move and you know the one trade that
gets made that we all have talked about
for years to come is often the one that
nobody saw coming
Howard appreciate the time appreciate
your work on bleacher report also the
full 48 podcast right here on the Rich
Eisen show thanks for joining always a
pleasure rich thank you at Howard back
on Twitter the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience